Here. They are. Just like you
said, even at their worst point
this season, they'll be back at
the top of the AFC.
And here they are how they get
here. How did they get to this
point in the season despite
their struggles?
Well, obviously the defense a
you talk about leadership and
making an impact. Melvin,
Ingram. He's come in and he's
made a difference. He's been a
big difference maker. You look
at Chris Jones and always see
would leadership leadership
isn't just about talking, but
it's out there, performing
and making a difference. And
Chris Jones has really
dominated the inside of that
defense. And you look at some
of those young linebackers. You
look at the growth of
the secondary led by Tyrann
Mathieu, and he's not
what you would call a very
physical safety,
you know. Coming up hitting 230
pound backs, but he's a guy
that knows how to position
himself because he's a smaller
guy, but he creates a lot of
turnovers and he keeps those
guys, he communicates with them.
I just like what they've done on
the defensive side of
the ball. They have a lot of
depth in the secondary. And
really,
for me. I think it comes down,
offensive leads to the growth
and the patience of Patrick
Mahomes. This is what we're
starting to see and
Patrick Mahomes. Andy Reid has
been drilling to him. If you
see that covered too, don't be
afraid to drop, you know,
dunk deep the ball.
All just dump it off
and I think he's done a really
good job of that. Even though
against the Chargers. They
started playing some cover
three handsome, man to man
coverage. He lit them up with
four touchdowns and over 400
yards. So
Patrick Mahomes is the type of
player. My whole point is this
Jack Patrick Mahomes is now he's
maturing into the type of
player. Where if he sees the two
safeties, he's patient
enough to dump it down.
If he sees the one, then he's
going to take shots. And of
course, he's got that boy.
Travis Kelce.
That's right. It's the maturity
Factor. They're going to have
to navigate some Covid stuff
too, because they had Tyree
kill show up with the Positive.
They had, Travis Kelce was on
the list as well. They got
Harrison buckers on the list as
well. That's three tough ones
and their to get ready to face
the AFC North Pittsburgh and
the Bangles. They have coming up
down the stretch. About
those teams can get dangerous.
If you're short.